for N and four of our ways to loop
through objects for n will loop through
property names and four of will loop
through property values here is the
basic usage we have four and you have to
put a variable in and then the object
name and then down here is what you want
to do and for up for the variable name
of object and then some statements of
what you want to do so that's the basic
usage let's look at some actual examples
I'm going to create a variable here let
person equal FF named Bo l name Karns
arms two because I do have two arms so
I'm gonna create this object person and
I'm also gonna create an array and we're
just gonna have three numbers in it
three five seven and then we're gonna
create a custom property on the array
and call it hello so first we're gonna
use the person object we created this
for in loop we're gonna have a variable
X in person here we're gonna loop
through the property names so I'm
showing that we're going to add
something to this text variable we're
gonna add person and then we're gonna
get the property name this is actually
just a way to add the property value to
text because when you have an object and
you in the bracket you put the property
name it's going to get the value of that
property and we add it to text and then
I'm gonna console dot log the property
name and then we're going to console dot
log text which is all the property
values that we added to up here let's
see that okay so you can see we have F
name L name and arms that's when we're
console logging X and X is always the
property name and then here we're
passing in the property value to text
and we're going to console that log text
okay now the of loop the for of loop
will not work on person because person
is not iterable the the for in loops
through innumerable properties while for
of loops through iterable objects such
as array map and set so let's just give
you an example we have this array here
and I'm going to create another loop I'm
going to show you four in and four of on
this one if you use four in on arrays it
will return the name of your user
defined properties in addition to the
numeric indexes this usually is not what
you want
when iterating over arrays you usually
want to use a traditional form loop so
let me show you what I mean so I made
the for and loop I'm just going to copy
that and when turn that into a for loop
and let's run that when we do the let I
in array I'm going to console dot log
that this is actually going to return
the numeric indexes look the array is
three five seven
but what we're returning is 0 1 2 and
then foo because 0 is the index of 3 1
is the index of 5 and 2 is the index of
7 because arrays just count 0 1 2 and so
on for the indexes and then we're also
going to return any user-defined
properties and we've said foo foo right
here is the user-defined property now
that's what the in loop is gonna do the
of loop is gonna be a little bit more of
what you expect it's just gonna go
through all the items in the array the
items in the array are 3 5 and 7
hello is not actually in the array it's
just the value of this user-defined
property so that's for in loops and for
of loops thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes check the description
for links for more information don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good